في اوكرانيا استراتيجيات وتكتيكات جديده
يسعى من خلالها
الرئيسكي الى تحويل المساعدات الغربيه من
اسلحه دفاعيه الى هجوميه تحصبا لمعركه
الربيع القادمه
بعد
دباباتول الالمانيه وابرمز الامريكيه
طائره اف 16 ملكيه الصنع على قائمه
اولويات زلانسكي التي يراها الوسيله
الوحيده للتصدي لهجمات الصواريخ والطائرات
بدون طياره روسيه
لازاله هذا الخيار للغازات لتدمير المدن
الاوكرانيه باستخدام قاذفات صواريخ منتشره
صاحبه بوليتيكو الامريكيه كشفت عن ضغوط
تمارسها مجموعه من ممثلي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه سرا على البنتاجون للموافقه على
ارسال طائرات مقاتله وصواريخ بعيده المدى
الى اوكرانيا
وفقه مراقبين فتغير منحى المساعدات باتجاه
الاسلحه الهجوميه يمكن ان يغير معادله
الحرب الدائره منذ نحو عام تقريبا فمع
الاستعداد لتنفيذ هجوم الربيع من طرف
الجيش الاوكراني اكتسبت توريد المحتمل
لطائره اف 16 زخاما كبيرا فالطائره تنتمي
الى الجيل الرابع من المقاتلات الحربيه
وتعد من اهم الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله
خفيفه الوزن في سرعه الطائرات تصل عند
اقصر ارتفاع لها الى اكثر من
2400 كم في الساعه كذلك يصل متوسط عدد
ساعات الطيران للطائره الواحده خلال عمرها
الافتراضي الى حوالي 12,000 ساعه طيران
تقريبا
بدت كيف اكثر عملا في ان تاخذ واشنطن
قرارا حاسما بشان تزويدها ب f16 لذا اعدت
قائمه تضم 50 طياره يمكنهم بدء التدريب
لتكون مستعده لمعركه الربيع